hello my name is nadja frantier
it's not about protecting the planet
anymore it's about our life our
livelihoods everything is connected and
um
what what you do matters i'm hopeful for
the future of the land that i am
protecting
we have a resident pod of orca we see
the orca on occasion once a week
[Music]
i'm the marine assistant at rather a
research station which is to the west of
the west antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
i really hope to build a more
comprehensive picture of what is
happening in antarctic ecosystems
over the season and also try and compare
this with past data so we can untangle
the effect of climate change of what is
just happening naturally
my name is
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
with life in future
[Music]
clinics and can lead to drought and this
drought can cause some wildlife like
lions and elephants to change their
position they can move from the national
park to
around the communities in search of
water and fastest
[Music]
the climate crisis is
you know one of the biggest existential
challenges that we've ever come across
as a species
for us to continue to grow we have to
have a positive impact we can no longer
just be sustainable or have a kind of
carbon neutral approach um we need to go
beyond that and we need to look at
carbon negative approaches and where's
ways in which we can always add value
and have a positive and regenerative
impact on the environment and society
with all of our practices
decline is the first experiment of a
house
building in clay through the wasp
company so we we matching the idea of an
old material we will mix
with the new technology 3d printing and
creating housing clay
maybe the future is also to look our
path
and discover the knowledge we are lost
in the last 250 years
i grew up seeing the impacts of climate
change firsthand
because climate education in the
philippines is so lacking i didn't even
make the connection between the typhoons
that i was already experiencing and the
greenhouse gas emissions i was talking
about i realized that i have no choice i
have
to join the struggle
of our environmental defenders and not
the people for a better planet a better
future a safe presence
i had to join the fight
[Music]
what's different about what we do at
kamoka is we bring the oysters into
shallow water zones where there's lots
of fish
all of the fish species that live on the
reef that they come to to clean the
oysters they all
become stronger and more numerous
[Music]
to do things the right way it's more
expensive it's easier to work the way
that the really big industrial farms
work
so i grew up on the ocean floating and
very much in touch with everything that
lives in it and on it i think it just
sort of ingrained in me a sense that
everything is connected and
what what you do matters
[Music]
we think we're superior because we can
walk straight and talk now and we fail
to understand that we're just one of the
several species in this planet
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms
[Music]
one thing which i've realized is
everybody wants to be good everybody
wants to participate in planet
conservation efforts they just don't
know where to begin
no action is small or insignificant
collectively we can really start to
address this in really creative and
interesting ways
i'm hopeful for the future of the land
that i am protecting i am hoping that
maybe deforestation will not be there
because we protect all species of
wildlife and plants also
it's just i think sustainability just is
a natural consequence of caring